[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome Dr Andrew
right
Andrew is the managing General partner
of AI fund
founder of deep learning AI
and learn and Landing AI chairman and
co-founder of Coursera
in an Adjunct professor of computer
science here at Stanford
previously he had started and led the
Google brain team which had helped
Google adopt modern Ai and he was also
director of the Stanford AI lab
about 8 million people one in one
thousand persons on the planet
have taken an AI class from him and
through both his education and his AI
work
he has changed numerous lives
please welcome Dr Andrew
[Music]
foreign
Thank you Lisa it's good to see everyone
so what I want to do today is um chat
you about some opportunities in AI so
I've been seeing AI is a new electricity
one of the difficult things to
understand about AI is that it is a
general purpose technology meaning that
it's not useful only for one thing but
it's useful for lots of different
applications kind of like electricity if
I was to ask you what is electricity
good for you know it's not any one thing
it's a lot of things so what I'd like to
do is start off sharing with you how I
view the technology landscape and this
will lead into the set of opportunities
so a lot of hype lots of excitement
about Ai and I think a good way to think
about AI is as a collection of tools so
this includes a technique called
supervised learning which is very good
at recognizing things or labeling things
and gents of AI which is relatively new
exciting development if you're familiar
with AI you may have heard of other
tools but I'm going to talk less about
these additional tools and I'll focus on
a on what I think are currently the two
most important tools which are
supervised learning and generative AI
so supervised learning is very good at
labeling things or very good at
Computing input to outputs or a to B
mappings given input a give me an output
B for example given an email we can use
supervised learning to label it as spam
or not spam the most lucrative
application of this that I've ever
worked on is probably online advertising
we're given an ad we can label our users
likely to click on it and therefore show
more relevant ads for self-driving calls
given the sensitive readings of a car we
can label it with where the other cars
one project that my team AI fan worked
on was ship route optimization where
given a route that the ship is taking or
considering taking we can label that
with how much fuel we think to consume
and use this uh make ships more fuel
efficient still a lot of work in
automated visual inspection in factories
so you can take a picture of a
smartphone that was just manufactured
and label is just scratched right near
the defect in it or if you want to build
a restaurant review reputation
monitoring system you can have little
piece of software that looks at online
restaurant reviews and labels that as
positive or negative sentiment so one
nice thing one cool thing about
supervised learning is that it's not
useful for one thing it's useful for all
of these different applications and many
more besides let me just walk through
you know concretely the workflow of one
example of a supervised learning
labeling things kind of project if you
want to build a system to label
restaurant reviews you then collect a
few data points or collect the data set
where say you know the pastrami sandwich
is great to say that is positive civil
is slow that's negative my favorite
chicken curry that's positive and
um here I've shown three data points
whether you're building this you may get
thousands of data points like this or
thousands of trading examples we call it
and the workflow of a machine learning
project or an AI project is you get
labeled data maybe thousands of you know
data points then you have an AI
engineering team trained an AI model to
learn from this data and then finally
you would find maybe a cloud service to
run the trained AI model and then you
can feed it you know best bubble tea
I've ever had and that's positive sense
of it and so I think the last decade was
maybe the decade of large-scale
supervised learning what we found
starting about 10 15 years ago was if
you were to train a small AI model to
train a small neural network with small
deep learning algorithm Basia small AI
model maybe not on a very powerful
computer then as you fed more data is
performance would get better for a
little bit but then it would flatten out
it would plateau and it would stop being
able to use the data to get better and
better
but if you were to train a very large AI
model lots of compute on maybe powerful
gpus then as we scaled up the amount of
data we gave the machine learning model
this performance would kind of keep on
getting better and better so this is why
when I started let the Google brain team
the primary mission that I directed the
team to solve at the time was let's just
build really really large neural
networks that we then fed a lot of data
to and that recipe fortunately worked
and I think the idea of driving large
compute and large scale of data that
recipes really helped us driven a lot of
AI progress over the last decade
so if that was the last decade of AI I
think this decade is turning out to be
also doing everything we had to
supervised learning but adding to it
um the exciting tool of genus of AI
so many of you maybe all of you will
play their chai GPT and Bob and so on
but just you know given a piece of text
which you call a prompt like I love
eating if you run this multiple times
maybe you get bagels cream cheese or my
Mother's Meatloaf or um Ultra friends
and the AI system can generate output
like that
um given the amounts of Buzz and
excitement about genes of AI I thought
I'd take just half a slide to you know
say a little bit about how this works
so it turns out that germs of AI at
least this type of text generation the
core of it is using supervised learning
that inputs output mappings to
repeatedly predict the next word and so
if your system reads on the Internet
it's a sentence like my favorite food is
a bagel with cream cheese and locks then
this is translated into a few data
points where if it sees my favorite food
is a in this case try to guess that the
right next word was Bagel or my favorite
food is a bagel try to guess next word
is with
um and similarly if it sees that you
know in this case the right guess for
the next word would have been cream
so by taking text that you find on the
internet or other sources and by using
this input output supervised learning to
try to repeatedly predict the next word
if you train a very large AI system
on hundreds of billions of words so in
the case of the largest models now more
than a trillion words then you get a
large language model like chai GP and
you know there are additional other
important technical details I talked
about predicting the next word
technically these systems predict the
next sub word or part of work called the
token and then there are other
techniques like rohf for further tuning
the AI output to be more helpful honest
and harmless but at the heart of it is
this using supervised learning to
repeatedly predict the next word that
that's really what's enabling
um the exciting you know really
fantastic progress on large language
models
so
um while many people have seen large
English models as a fantastic consumer
tool you can go to a website like track
GPS website or Bots or other large
language models and use it I think it's
fantastic too there's one of the trends
I think is still underappreciated which
is the power of large language models
not only not just as consumer two but as
a developer to
so it turns out that um there are
applications that used to take me months
to build that a lot of people can now
build much faster by using a large
language model so specifically the
workflow for supervised learning
building the restaurant review system
say would be that you need to get a
bunch of label data and you know maybe
that takes a month to get a few thousand
data points and then have an AI team
train and tune and really get you know
optimized performance on your AI model
maybe that'll take three months
then find a cloud service to run it make
sure it's running robustly make sure
it's recognized maybe that'll take
another three months
so pretty realistic timeline for
building a commercial grade machine
Learning System is like six to 12 months
right so teams I've LED will often took
you know roughly six to 12 months to
build and deploy these systems and and
some of them turned out to be really
valuable uh but this is a realistic
timeline for building and deploying a
commercial grade AI system
in contrast with prompt base AI we write
a prompt this is what the workflow looks
like
you can specify a prompt that takes
maybe minutes or hours and then you can
deploy it to the cloud and that takes
maybe hours or days so there are certain
AI applications that used to take me you
know literally six months maybe a year
to build that many teams around the
world can now build in maybe a week and
I think this is already starting but the
best is still yet to come this is
starting to open up a flood of a lot
more AI applications that can be built
by a lot of people so I think many
people still underestimate the magnitude
of the floods of custom AI applications
that I think is going to come down the
pipe
now I know you probably were not
expecting me to write code in this
presentation
but that's what I'm going to do
um
so it turns out this is all the code I
need
um in order to write a sentiment
classifier
so I'm gonna you know some of you will
know python I guess important tools from
open Ai and then I have this prompt that
says classify the text to below
delimited by three dashes as having
either a positive or negative sentiment
I don't know I
I don't know what I rather fantastic
time back at Stanford GSB
on we learned a lot and also made great
new friends all right so that's my
prompt and now I'm just gonna run it and
I've never run it before so I really
hope oh thank goodness we got the right
answer
and this is literally all the code it
takes to build a sentiment classifier
um and so today you know developers
around the world can take literally
maybe like 10 minutes to build a system
like this
um and
that's a very exciting development
so
one of the things I've been working on
was
um trying to teach you know online
classes about how to use prompting not
just as a consumer too but as a
developer too so stop the technology
landscape let me now
share my thoughts on what are some of
the AI opportunities I see
this shows what I think is the value of
different AI Technologies today
um and I'll talk about three years from
now but the vast majority of financial
value from AI today is I think
supervised learning where for a single
company like Google can be worth more
than 100 billion US dollars a year and
also there are millions of developers
building supervised learning
applications so it's already massively
valuable and also with tremendous
momentum behind it just because of the
sheer efforts in you know Finding
applications and building applications
and then generative AI is the really
exciting new entrance which is much
smaller right now
and then there are the other tools I'm
including for completeness we can you
know
the size of these circles represent the
value today this is what I think it
might grow to in three years
so supervised learning already really
massive May double say in the next three
years from truly massive to even more
massive
and gents of AI which is much smaller
today I think we're much more than
double in the next three years because
of the number of amounts of developer
interests the amount of venture capital
Investments number of large corporates
exploring applications and I also just
point out three years is a very short
time Horizon if it continues to compound
anything near this rate then in six
years you know it'll be it'll be even
vastly larger but um this light shaded
region in green or orange that light
shaded region is where the options is
for either new startups or for large
companies incumbents to create and to
enjoy value capture but one thing I hope
you take away from this slide is that
all of these Technologies are general
purpose Technologies so in the case of
supervised learning a lot of the work
that had to be done over the last decade
but it's continuing for the next decade
is identified and execute on the
concrete use cases and that process is
also kicking off for um generative AI
so for this part of the presentation I
hope you take away from it that general
purpose Technologies are useful for many
different tasks a lot of value remains
we created using civilized learning and
and even though we're nowhere near
finishing figuring out the exciting use
cases of supervised learning we have
this other you know fantastic two of
Genesis AI which further extends the set
of things we can now do using AI
um but one caveat which is that there
will be short-term fans along the way so
I don't know if um some of you might
remember the app called lenser This is
the app that will let you upload
pictures of yourself and they'll render
a cool picture of you as an astronaut or
a scientist or something
um and it was a good idea and people
liked it and it's really just took off
like crazy like that through last
December
and then it did that
and that's because lenser was it was a
good idea people liked it but it was a
relatively thin software layer on top of
someone else's really powerful apis
um and so even though it was a it was a
useful product it was in a defensible
business
um and when I when I one thing about you
know apps like lenser
um I'm actually reminded that when Steve
Jobs gave us the iPhone shortly after
someone wrote an app that I paid 199 for
um to do this to turn on the LED to turn
the phone into the flashlight and that
was also a good idea to write an app to
turn on the LED light but it also wasn't
a defensible long-term it also didn't
create very long-term value because it
was a easily replicated and underpriced
and eventually incorporated into iOS
but with the rise of iOS with the rise
of the iPhone someone also figured out
how to build things like uber and Airbnb
and Tinder the very long-term very
defensible businesses that created you
know sustaining value and I think with
um the rise of gents of AI or the rise
of new AI tools I think what really what
excites me is the opportunity to create
those really deep really hard
applications that hopefully can create
very long-term value
so the first Trend I want to share is
ai's general purpose technology and a
lot of the work that lies ahead of us is
to find the very diverse use cases and
to build them
there's a second Trend I want to share
with you which relates to why AI isn't
more widely adopted yet
it feels like a bunch of us have been
talking about AI for like 15 years or
something but if you look at where the
value of AI is today a lot of it is
still very concentrated in consumer
software internet right once you go
outside you know Tech or consumer
software internet there's some air
adoption but a lot of views very early
so why is that
it turns out if you were to take all
current and potential AI projects and
sort them in decreasing all their value
then to the left of this curve the head
of this curve are the multi-billion
dollar projects like advertising or web
search or um for e-commerce your product
recommendations your company Amazon and
it turns out that about 10 15 years ago
you know variously my friends and I we
figured out a recipe for how to hire say
100 Engineers to write one piece of
software to serve more relevant ads and
apply that one piece of software to
billion users and generate massive
Financial value so that works
um
but once you go outside consumer
software internet hardly anyone has a
hundred million or a billion users that
you can write and apply one piece of
software to
so once you go to other Industries as we
go from the head of this curve on the
left over to the long tail these are
some of the projects I see and I'm
excited about
I was working with a pizza maker that
was taking pictures of the Pisa they
were making because they needed to do
things like make sure that the cheese is
spread evenly so this is about a five
million dollar project
um but that recipe of hiring 100
Engineers or dozens of Engineers to work
on a five million dollar project that
doesn't make sense
um or there's another very example
working with an agriculture company that
with them we figured out that we use
cameras to find out how tall is the
wheat and wheat is often bent over
because of wind or rain or something and
we can chop off the weeds at the very
height then that results in more food
for the farmer to sell and it's also
better for the environment but this is
another you know five million dollar
project that that old recipe of having a
large group of Highly School Engineers
to work on this one project that doesn't
make sense
um and some of the materials grading
cloth grading sheet metal grading many
projects like this
so whereas to the left in the head of
this curve there's a small number of
let's say multi-billion dollar projects
and we know how to execute those you
know delivering value in other
Industries I'm seeing a very long tale
of tens of thousands of let's call them
five million dollar projects that until
now have been very difficult to excuse
on because of the high cost of
customization
the trend that I think is exciting is
that the AI Community has been building
better tools that lets us aggregate
these use cases and make it easy for the
end user to do the customization so
specifically I'm seeing a lot of
exciting low code and no code tools that
enable the user to customize the AI
system what this means is instead of me
needing to worry that much about
pictures of Pisa we have tools because
we're starting to see tools that can
enable the I.T Departments of the pizza
making factory to train an AI system on
their own pages of Pisa to realize
there's five million dollars worth of
value
and by the way the pictures of pizza you
know they don't exist on the internet so
Google and Bing don't have access to
these pictures we need tools that can be
used by really The Pizza Factory
themselves to build and deploy and
maintain their own custom AI system that
works on their own pictures of pizza
and broadly
the technology for enabling this
um some of it is prompting with text
prompting visual prompting but really
large language models and and similar
tools like that or a technology called
Data Centric AI whereby instead of
asking the Pizza Factory to write a lot
of code yeah which is which which is
challenging we can ask them to provide
data which turns out to be more feasible
and I think the second trend is
important because I think this is a key
part of the recipe for taking the value
of AI which so far still feels very
concentrated in the tech world and the
consumer software into their world and
pushing this out to you know all
Industries really to the rest of the
economy which which you know sometimes
is easy to forget the rest of the
economy is much bigger than the tech
world
so
there are two Trends I shared it has a
general purpose technology lots of
concrete use cases to be realized as
well as local no code easily used tools
enabling AI to be deployed in more
Industries how do we go after these
opportunities
so about five years ago there was a
puzzle I want to solve which is I felt
that many valuable AI projects are now
possible I was thinking how do we get
them done and having LED AI teams in you
know Google and Baidu in big tech
companies I had a hard time figuring out
how I could operate a team in a big tech
company to go after a very diverse set
of opportunities and everything from
Maritime shipping to education to
financial services and Healthcare and on
and on it's just very diverse use cases
very diverse go to markets and very
diverse really you know customer bases
and applications
um and I felt that the most efficient
way to do this would be if we can start
a lot of different companies to pursue
these very diverse opportunities so
that's why I ended up starting AI fun
which is Adventure Studio that builds
startups to pursue a diverse surveyor
opportunities and of course in addition
to lots of startups in company companies
also have a lot of opportunities to
integrate AI into existing businesses in
fact one pattern I'm seeing for
incumbent businesses is um distribution
uh is is often one of the significant
advantages of incoming companies is they
play the cards right can allow them to
integrate AI into into their products
quite efficiently
but just be Concrete where are the
options
so I think of this as a this is what I
think of as the AI stack
right at the bottom level is the
hardware semiconductor layer fantastic
opportunities there but very Capital
intensive very concentrated so there's a
lot of resources relatively few winners
so some people can and should play there
I personally don't like to play them
myself
there's also the infrastructure layer
also fantastic opportunities but very
couple intensive very concentrated so I
tend not to play that myself either
and then does it develop a two layer
what I showed you just now was I was
actually using open ai's API as a
developer tool and then I think the
developer 2 sector is hyper competitive
look at all the startups chasing open AI
right now but there will be some Mega
winners and so I sometimes play here but
primarily when I think of a meaningful
technology Advantage because I think
that earns you the right or earns you a
better shot at being one of the mega
winners
and then lastly even though a lot of the
media attention in the buzz is in the
infrastructure and developer tooling
layer it turns out that that layer can
be successful only if the application
layer is even more successful and we saw
this at the rise of SAS as well a lot of
the buzz excitement is on the technology
the tooling layer which is fine nothing
wrong with that but the only way for
that to be successful is that the
application layer is even more
successful so that frankly they can
generate enough Revenue to pay the
infrastructure and the tooling layer so
actually let me mention one example
um I'm all right I was actually just
texting the CEO yesterday but armor raw
is a completely rebuilt that uses AI for
romantic relationship coaching right
um and Jesus points out I'm an AI guy
and I feel like I know nothing really
about Romance
um and if you don't believe me you can
ask my wife if she will confirm that I
know nothing about Romance
but what we want to build this we wanted
getting together with the former CEO of
Tinder or Renata and eyeball and with my
team's expertise in Ai and her expertise
in relationships we actually ran Tinder
she knows more about you know
relationships I think anyone I know
we're able to build something pretty
unique using AI for you know kind of
romantic relationship mentoring
um and the interesting thing about
applications like these is when we look
around
um you know how many teams in the world
are simultaneously expert in Ai and in
relationships and so at the application
layer I'm seeing a lot of exciting
opportunities that seem to have a very
large Market but where the competition
sets is very light relative to the
magnitude of the opportunity it's not
that they're no competitors but it's
just much less intense compared to the
developer 2 or the infrastructure layer
and so
because I've spent a lot of time
iterating on the process of building
startups what I'm going to do is just
you know very transparently tell you the
recipe we've developed for building
startups and so after many years of
iteration and Improvement this is how
you know we now build startups my team's
always had access to a lot of different
ideas you know internally generated
ideas from partners and I want to walk
through this with one example or
something we did which is a company
bearing AI which uses AI to make ships
more fuel efficient
so this idea came to me when a few years
ago a large Japanese conglomerate called
mitsui that is a major shareholder in
the Opera is a major Shipping Lines they
came to me and they said hey Andrew you
should build a business to use AI to
make ships more fuel efficient and the
specific idea was you know think of it
as a Google Maps for ships where you can
suggest a ship or towership how to steer
so you still get your destination on
time by using it turns out about 10 less
fuel
um and so what we now do is we spend
about a month validating the idea so
double check is this idea even
technically feasible and then talk to
prospective customers to make sure this
is marketing so you spend up to about a
month doing that and if it passes this
stage then we will go and recruit the
CEO to work with us on the project when
I was starting out I used to spend a
long time working on the project myself
before bringing on the CEO but after
iterating we realized that bringing on
the leader at the very beginning to work
with us it reduces a lot of the burden
of having to transfer knowledge or
having a seal come in and rebound having
to revalidate whether we discover it so
the process is we've learned much more
efficiently which is bringing the leader
at the very start
um and so in the case of bearing AI we
found a fantastic CEO Dylan Kyle who's a
repeat entrepreneur a one successful
exhibit before and then we spent three
months um six two weeks Sprints to work
with them to build a prototype as well
as do do deep customer validation
if it survives the stage and we have
about two-thirds 66 survival rate
whenever the first check-in which then
gives the company resources to hire an
executive team you know build the key
team get the MVP working minimum viable
product working and get some real
customers and then after that you know
hopefully then successfully raises
additional external rounds of funding
they can keep on growing and scaling
so I'm really proud of the work that my
team was able to do
um to support mitsui's idea and telling
how as CEO and today there are hundreds
of ships on the high seas right now that
are steering themselves differently
because of bearing Ai and um 10 fuel
savings translates the rough order
amount to maybe 450 000 in savings and
Fuel per ship per year and of course
it's also frankly quite a bit better for
the environment
um and I think the startup
I think would not have to existed if not
for Dylan's fantastic work and then also
you know mitsui brings this idea to me
and I like this example because this is
another one it's like you know this is a
startup idea that I just point out I
would never have come up with myself
right because you know I've been on a
boat but what do I know about Maritime
shipping
um but it's the deep subject matter
expertise of mitsui
um that had this inside together with
Dylan and then my team's expertise in AI
that that made this possible and so as I
operate in AI one thing I've learned is
my swim Lane is AI and that's it because
I've done a time it was very difficult
for me to be expert in Maritime shipping
and romantic relationships and
Healthcare and financial services on and
on and on and so I've learned that if I
can just help get a accurate technical
validation and then use you know AI
resources to make sure that AI Tech has
been quickly and well and I think with
all always managed to hope the companies
build a strong technical team then
partnering with subject matter experts
often results in exciting New
Opportunities
and I want to share with you one other
weird aspect of another one of the weird
listing I've learned about you know
building startups which is
um I like to engage only when there's a
concrete idea
and this runs counter to a lot of the
advice you hear from the design thinking
methodology which often says don't rush
to solutioning right explore a lot of
alternatives for either a solution
honestly we tried that it was very slow
um but what we've learned is that at the
ideation stage is someone comes to me
and says hey Andrew you should apply AI
to financial services
because I'm not a subject matter expert
in financial services is very slow for
me to go and learn enough about
financial services so you can figure out
what to do I mean eventually you could
get a good outcome but it's a very labor
intensive very slow very expensive
process for me to try to learn industry
after industry
in contrast one of my partners wrote
this idea as a tongue-in sheet not not
really seriously but you know let's say
the country is buy gbt let's eliminate
commercials by automatically buying
every product advertising it's changed
or not haven't seen any ads it's not a
good idea but it is a concrete idea
and it turns out concrete ideas can be
validated or falsified efficiently
um they also give a team a clear
direction to execute and I've learned
that in today's world especially with
you know the excitement Buzz the
exposure the AI of a lot of people it
turns out that there are a lot of
subject matter experts in today's world
that have deeply thought about the
problem for months sometimes even you
know one or two years but they've not
yet had a bill partner and when we get
together with them and hear and they
share the idea of us it allows us to
work with them to very quickly go into
validation and building and I find that
this works because there are a lot of
people that have already done the you
know design thinking thing of exploring
a lot of ideas and running down to
really good ideas and there I find that
there's so many good ideas sitting out
there that no one is working on on that
finding those good ideas that someone
has already had and wants to share of us
that wants to build partner for that
turns out to be much more efficient
engine
so
um before I wrap up we'll go to question
a second just a few slices talk about
risks and social impact
um
so yeah it's very powerful technology to
State something you probably guess my
teams and I we only work on projects
that move Humanity forward and you know
we have multiple times cool projects
that we assess to be financially sound
uh based on ethical grounds it turns out
I've been surprised and sometimes
dismayed at the creativity of people to
come up with good ideas so to come up
with really bad ideas that that seem
profitable but really should not be
built um we'll kill a few projects on
those on those drones
and then I think has to be acknowledge
the AI today does have problems with
bias fairness accuracy
um but also you know the technology is
improving quickly so I see that AI
systems today are less biased than six
months ago and more fair than six months
ago which is not to dismiss the
importance of these problems they are
problems and we should continue to work
on them but I'm also gratified at the
number of aits working hard on these
issues to make them much better
when I think of the biggest risk of AI I
think that because there is one of the
biggest there is is the disruption to
jobs
um this is a diagram from a paper by our
friends at the University of
Pennsylvania and some folks at open AI
analyzing the exposure of different jobs
to AI Automation and it turns out that
whereas the previous wave of automation
mainly the most exposed jobs were often
the lower wage jobs such as when you
know we put robots into factories with
this current wave of automation is
actually the highway shops further to
the right of this apps is that seems to
have more of their tasks expose the AI
automation
so
um even as we create tremendous value
using AI I feel like as Citizens
um and and our corporations and the
governments and really our society I
feel a strong obligation to make sure
that
um people especially people whose
livelihoods are disrupted are still well
taken care of are still treated well
and then lastly
um there's also been it feels like every
time there's a big wave of progress in
AI you know there's a there's a big wave
of hype about artificial gender
intelligence as well when deep learning
start to work really well 10 years ago
there was a lot of hype about AGI and
now the genify is working really well
there's another wave of hyper by AGI
um but I think that artificial gender
intelligence AI didn't do anything a
human can do it's still decades away you
know maybe 30 to 50 years maybe even
longer I hope we'll see it in a
lifetimes but I don't think as anytime
soon one of the challenges is that
the biological path to intelligence like
humans and the digital path to
intelligence you know AI they've taken
very different paths and the funny thing
about the definition of AGI is yeah
benchmarking there's very different
digital Parts intelligence with really
the biological part of intelligence so I
think you know large English models are
smarter than any of us in certain key
Dimensions but much dumber than any of
us in other dimensions and so forcing it
to do everything a human can do is like
a funny comparison
um but I hope we'll get there maybe
hopefully within our lifetimes and then
there's also a lot of I think overblown
hype about AI creating Extinction risk
for Humanity
um candidly I don't see it I just don't
see how AI creates any meaningful
Extinction rest of humanity
um I think that people worry we can't
control AI but we have lots of AI will
be more powerful than any person but
with lots of experience steering very
powerful entities such as corporations
or nation states that are far more
powerful than any single person and
making sure they for the most part
benefit humanity and also technology
develops gradually the so-called hard
takeoff scenario where it's not really
working today and then suddenly one day
overnight it works brilliantly in which
is super intelligent takes over world
that's just not realistic and I think AI
technology would develop slowly like all
that you know like and then it gives us
plenty of time to make sure that we
provide oversight and can manage it to
be safe
and lastly if you look at the real
Extinction rest of humanity
um such as fingers crossed the next
pandemic or climate change leading to a
massive depopulation of some parts of
the planets or much lower odds but maybe
someday and as there are doing to us
what it had done to the dinosaurs I
think if you look the actual real
Extinction risk to humanity AI having
more intelligence even artificial
intelligence in the world would be a key
part of the solution so I feel like if
you want Humanity to survive and thrive
for the next Thousand Years rather than
slowing AI down which some people
propose I would mother I would rather
maybe ai go as fast as possible
um some of that just to summarize this
is my last line I think that AI as a
general purpose technology creates a lot
of new opportunities for everyone and a
lot of the excisely and important work
that lies ahead of us all is to go and
build those concrete use cases and
hopefully in the future hopefully I have
options to maybe engage with more of you
on those opportunities as well so that
let me just say thank you all very much
[Applause]